HIGHER EDUCATION TO ORDER.
WELCOME NEW MEMBERS MR GABRIEL.
ARE A NEW VICE CHAIR MISTER CHOI.
AND THE NEW CONSULTANT ON THE
REPUBLICAN SIDE.
WELCOME TO ALL.
FIRST ORDER OF BUSINESS IS TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
SO MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
TINA PRESIDENT.
CHOI PRESIDENT ARAMBULA.
BLOOM [inaudible]
GABRIEL [inaudible]
IRWIN [inaudible]
KILEY LEVINE [inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
PATTERSON SANTIAGO WEBER.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
MR SO AGAIN I WANT TO WELCOME
THE FIRST BILL HEARING.
OF THE ASSEMBLY HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE.
PLEASED TO ANNOUNCE THAT CHECK
NICKEL IS BACK.
AS HE WAS LAST YEAR AS PRISONERS
BOTH PRINCIPAL CONSULTANT TO THE
COMMITTEE.
ALSO WANT TO WELCOME ELIZABETH
ANYA THE NEW REPUBLICAN CAUCUS
CONSULTANT.
WHO IS NO ON THE COMMITTEE?
AND PLEASE NOTE OUR GENERAL
GUIDELINE FOR BILLS HEARD IN
THIS COMMITTEE IS TO ALLOW FOR
TESTIMONY FROM TWO WITNESSES FOR
SUPPORT.
AND TWO WITNESSES FOR OPPOSITION
EACH SPEAKING FOR TWO MINUTES.
STAKEHOLDER GROUPS AND ENTITIES
THAT ARE.
NOR IN OPPOSITION WILL BE
ALLOWED TO GIVE THEIR TESTIMONY
FOR NO MORE THAN TWO MINUTES
WHEN I CALL FOR TWEETERS.
THE MEASURE HAS MORE THAN TWO
ENTITIES AND THE TWEENER
CATEGORY ONLY TWO WILL BE
ALLOWED TO SPEAK FOR TWO MINUTES
EACH.
THE FIRST ORDER OF BUSINESS IS
ADOPTION OF THE COMMITTEE RULES
CAN I HAVE A MOTION MISTER CHAIR
LIKE TO MOVE AN APPROVAL THE
RULES THEN MOOD AND MAY HAVE A
SECOND.
SECOND BY DR WEBER.
SO WAS MOVED BY MISTER LEVINE
SECOND BY DOCTOR WEBER MADAM
SECRETARY READ PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
MEDINA.
I MEDINA I CHOI [inaudible]
THIS THING [inaudible]
NOT.
FORTY CHOI NOT VOTING ARAMBULA.
BLOOM [inaudible]
GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I WHEN --
WHEN I KILEY LEVINE?
LEVINE I LOW LOW I PATTERSON.
SANTIAGO WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER II [inaudible]
WHEN?
OKAY WE WILL WE'LL KEEP THE ROLE
OPEN. FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
WE GET WE WE CAN'T MOVE WE CAN
CAN WE HEAR THE BILLS --
AS A COMMITTEE AS A SUBCOMMITTEE.
WAIT FIRST THE FIRST WE HAVE TO
PASS OUR RULES FIRST.
WE'RE ABSENT A A MEMBER
.
OPEN THE ROLL UP AGAIN FOR
ADOPTION OF THE RULES
[inaudible] THREE ARAMBULA
[inaudible]
BLOOM [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
KILEY PATTERSON SANTIAGO. SEVEN
ZERO THE RULES PASSED NOW WE CAN
BEGIN.
AND THE GOING IN OF SIGN IN
ORDER FIRST ITEM.
AB EIGHT TO THIRTY NINE MR SALAS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
THE COMMITTEE A PRESENT BEFORE
YOU AB TWO THIRTY NINE WOULD
EXTEND THE SUNSET ON CURRENT LAW
TO ALLOW CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE.
NURSING PROGRAMS TO UTILIZE THE
MULTI CRITERIA SCREENING TOOL
FOR ADMISSIONS BY THIS MULTI
COULD.
CRITERIA SCREENING TOOL ALLOWS
NURSING PROGRAMS TO ADDRESS THE
IMPACT ON MISSIONS BY ASSESSING
A CANDIDATE'S QUALIFICATIONS.
AND THEREFORE DECREASES
ATTRITION RATES BY ENSURING THE
ENTRANCE TO THE PROGRAMMER
ADEQUATELY PREPARED TO UNDERTAKE
THE COURSE REQUIREMENTS.
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
BUT THE BILL.
WITNESSES AND IN SUPPORT.
A GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRED MEMBERS
JUSTIN SILICON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
BOARD OF GOVERNORS THE SPONSOR
OF AB.
TWO THIRTY NINE IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN THE MULTI CRITERIA
SCREENING TOOL WAS DEVELOPED BY
NURSING PROGRAMS IN THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE IN ORDER TO
LOWER ATTRITION RATES.
AND IT IMPROVE SUCCESS RATES FOR
ALL STUDENT GROUPS.
AND OVER THE YEARS THE
PARTICULARS SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN WHEN THIS --
MULTI CRITERIA SCREENING TOOLS
LAST RE AUTHORIZE WE SEEN AN
INCREASE IN PROGRAMS --
USING THE TOOL --
YOU TO SEE MORE PROGRAMS ADD ON
AS WE GO FORWARD --
I HAVE WITH ME DOCTOR CAROL
MOUNTAIN NURSING DIRECTOR AT
SACRAMENTO CITY COLLEGE TO GO
INTO MORE DETAIL ON HOW.
THE MULTI CRITERIA SCREEN TOOL.
THE BENEFITS OF IT --
AT THE COLLEGES THANK YOU.
CHASING MY NAME AGAIN.
I'M DOCTOR CAROL MOUNTAIN I'M
FROM SACRAMENTO CITY COLLEGE WE
USE THE MULTI SCREENING CRITERIA
AS DO MANY OF OUR SISTER SCHOOLS.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND WE
FOUND IT VERY SUCCESSFUL IN
HELPING US TO DECREASE OUR
ATTRITION RATES AND TO MAKE SURE
THAT STUDENTS ARE PREPARED FOR
THE RIGOR OF THE NURSING
PROGRAMS.
SOME OF THE INFLUENCING FACTORS
THAT HAVE COME TO PLAY IN THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS AS THE FOCUS
ON SAFE PATIENT CARE.
THE NEED FOR A STAFF HIGH
FACULTY TO STUDENT RATIOS THAT
ARE MANDATED BY OUR CLINICAL
AGENCIES AND ARE LIMITED
QUALIFIED FACULTY TO TEACH THE
STUDENTS.
SO IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE BRING
STUDENTS INTO THE PROGRAMS THAT
ARE FULLY PREPARED AND
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE NEXT TWO
YEARS ARE GOING TO BE LIKE FOR
THEM -- THE
MULTI CARTER'S SELECTION --
PROVIDES THIS AVENUE FOR
STUDENTS TO BE PREPARED FOR THE
RIGORS OF OUR PROGRAM AND TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE ARE WAYS TO
REMEDIATE BEFORE COMING INTO THE
PROGRAM.
SO THAT THEY CAN BE PREPARED TO
NOT ONLY BE COMPLETE AS OF OUR
PROGRAM BUT TO PASS AND COLLECTS
AND THE PRAXIS AS REGISTERED
NURSES SO WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THIS BILL AND HOPE
THAT IT WILL STAY WITH US
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
SUPPORT.
OKAY I THINK WE THE THE RULES
THAT I READ WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE
TWO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF BUT
I THOUGHT I COULD JUST LISTEN.
THE YEAH THIS IS WHO THEY ARE
AND OKAY.
ALRIGHT BUT LET ME LET ME KNOW
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION OKAY.
AND IF THERE ARE --
NO WHICH IS IN OPPOSITION AND
AND THEN [inaudible]
WILL BEGIN.
WITH THE WITNESSES AND AND
SUPPORT WHEN IT COME UP AND GIVE
THEIR NAMES.
AND INNOVATION THAT THERE WITH
HER MARK MCDONALD MCCALLUM GROUP
ON BEHALF OF THE KERN AND FOOT
DE ANZA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS THAT BOTH UTILIZE THIS
PROCESS IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
HER COMMENTS AS CHAIR.
PLEASE YEAH I DON'T WANNA HEAR
SOME DETAILS ABOUT THE YOUR YOUR
YOUR MULTI CRITERIA SCREENING --
MEASURES SO --
HALL RECORDS OF WHAT IT IS.
SO WE USE THE A STUDY THAT WAS
DONE BY THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE.
AND WE LOOK AT THEIR STUDENTS
OVERALL GPA SO YOU'RE LOOKING AT
ENGLISH PSYCHOLOGY --
NUTRITION NUTRITION NOW THEY
TAKE CONTRITION WELL SOME
SCHOOLS DO NUTRITION SO AND AT
LIKE ANTHROPOLOGY OR SOCIOLOGY
SO THAT'S ONE CATEGORY THEN IN A
SEPARATE CATEGORY YOU HAVE YOUR
SCIENCES WHICH IS MICROBIOLOGY --
ANATOMY AND PHYSIOLOGY AND WE
KNOW THAT FOR THAT IF A STUDENT
GETS A B. AVERAGE A THREE POINT
NO IN THOSE THREE CLASSES
WHETHER IT'S DONE BY GETTING ALL
BEES OR IN A A C. A B..
IT DOESN'T SEEM TO MATTER BUT IF
THEY HIT THAT BE AVERAGE.
THAT THEN THEIR CHANCES OF
COMPLETING THE PROGRAM AND
PASSING AND COLLECTS IS
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER.
SO AT SACRAMENTO CITY COLLEGE
I'M NOT SURE ABOUT DELTA BUT
MOST OF THE SCHOOLS DO IT THE
SAME WE GIVE POINTS --
FOR BEING A VETERAN WE GIVE
POINTS --
FOR SPEAKING A SECOND LANGUAGE
HARDSHIP WHICH MOST OF OUR
STUDENTS TO HAVE HARDSHIP AND WE
DEFINE THAT VERY BROADLY --
JUST DEPENDING FIRST GENERATION
GOING LOW INCOME --
THEY GET POINTS IF THEY HAVE
ANOTHER LIFE IN A RESTAURANT
THERAPIST OR YOU'VE BEEN A FULL
BOTTOM MISSED YOU GET ADDITIONAL
POINTS FOR THAT AND THEN WE USE
THE TEAS TEST ARE YOU FAMILIAR
WITH THAT.
SO IT'S A ED TEST THAT
DETERMINES BASIC PROFICIENCY IN
READING AND SCIENCE AND MATH.
AND WE EVERY SCHOOL HAS A WAY
THAT A STUDENT CAN REMEDIATE
THEIR TEAS TEST THAT HAS TO BE
PUT IN PLACE.
BUT THAT TEST HELPS TO KNOW THAT
THE STUDENT IS PREPARED FOR THE
AMOUNT OF READING THAT GOES ON
WE MIGHT ASK THE STUDENT TO READ
A HUNDRED PAGES A WEEK.
EASILY AND SO THEY HAVE TO BE
ABLE TO READ AND COMPREHEND THAT
INFORMATION AND THE TEAS TEST IS
ONE WAY FOR THEM TO DETERMINE IF
THEY NEED TO TAKE AN ADDITIONAL
READING CLASS OR IF THEY NEED --
TO STUDY UP ON MATH OR SCIENCE
BEFORE THEY COME INTO THE
PROGRAM SO THAT WHEN THEY COME
INTO OUR FIRST SEMESTER THEY ARE
PREPARED FOR THE THE RIGOR AND
THE ANATOMY AND PHYSIOLOGY
BASICS.
THAT HAVE TO BE KNOWN TO BUILD
ON TOP OF THAT DOES THAT EXPLAIN
IT TO YOU.
YES IS THIS SO.
MUCH THAT CRITERIA SCREENING
MANAGER IS --
THRALL THE OLD.
A COMMUNITY COLLEGES SO WITH A
NURSING PROGRAMS.
WHAT A STORY OF THEM --
AND SOME ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
INSTITUTING IT RIGHT NOW --
THE SMALLER COLLEGES WHERE THEY
HAVE LESS RESOURCES YOU HAVE TO
DO A STUDY AT TO SAY THESE ARE
THE FACTORS THAT WE CAN PUT IN
PLACE RELATED TO THE ENVIRONMENT
AROUND OUR COLLEGE AND WHAT
EFFECTS IT.
SO SOME OF THE SMALLER SCHOOLS
IS THEY DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES
TO DO IT BUT AS MORE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES HAVE PUT THIS IN PLACE.
EVERYBODY IS ON BOARD ALL OF
THEM ARE WILL HAVE INSTITUTED
EVENTUALLY.
OBVIOUSLY I WERE TO SUPPORT THE
IS -- A. B.
TWO THIRTY NINE BUT UP BY
PASSING THIS MANAGER --
WOULD IT THE MANDATE THOUGHT ALL
THE COMMIT COLLEGES SO TO COMPLY.
NO THERE'S NO MANDATE AND THE
BILL IT'S IT'S IT'S OPTIONAL FOR
DISTRICTS TO UTILIZE THIS.
SO THAT WAY I BELIEVE WAS FORTY
MATTER WAS THE VALUE OF THIS
TODAY THAN IF WE DO PASS.
SO I THINK TO ANSWER YOUR
PREVIOUS QUESTION I BELIEVE THIS
IS AN FORTY TWO OF THE NURSING
FORTY TWO NURSING PROGRAMS
CURRENTLY IMPLEMENTED AM CST.
AND WHAT IT DOES IS BASICALLY
DESIGNED TO ALLOW THOSE STUDENTS
TO HAVE THE MOST SUCCESS IN
ACTUALLY GRADUATING FROM THESE
NURSING PROGRAMS BECAUSE THEY'RE
SO IMPACTED.
YOU'VE SEEN THE RISE AND HEALTH
CARE AND HEALTH CARE NEEDS
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE STATE OF
SURE.
IN YOUR DISTRICT AS WELL AND SO
WITH THIS CRITERIA DOES IS IT
ALLOWS A LOCAL COMMUNITY
COLLEGES TO UTILIZE AM CST SO WE
CAN.
HAVE HIGH GRADUATION RATES FOR
THESE NURSING PROGRAMS AND
FULFILL THAT NEED THAT WE ALL
HAVE IN ALL OF OUR COMMUNITIES
UP AND DOWN THE ENTIRE STATE.
AND THIS IS WHAT THIS BILL WILL
CONTINUE TO ALLOW THOSE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO DEVELOP
THE M. C. S. T. PROGRAM IF THEY
HAVEN'T DONE SO ALREADY.
AND FOR THOSE COLLEGES THAT HAVE
IT TO CONTINUE TO OUR HEALTH
CARE NEEDS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
YES SENSE OF THIS SOUNDS GOOD
THAT AND ARE NOT A SURE THAT THE
GRADUATION RATE THE WOULD BE
HIGH.
BECAUSE ALL WHILE WE IF WE MAKE
IT --
MANDATED HELPFUL.
MANY COLLEGES WITH THE NURSING
PROGRAM SO WARMLY --
GIVE THEM ANY HARDSHIP.
NO I THINK WHAT YOU'RE HEARING
FROM EVERYONE IN SUPPORT IS WERE
ALLOWING EACH OF THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES --
TO MOVE ALONG THIS PATH AND
THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE DOING
THEY'RE CONTINUING TO MOVE THAT
WAY THE PROGRAM STARTED WITH A
FEW COMMUNITY COLLEGES IT'S
GROWN TO FORTY TWO NOW.
AND WE'RE HOPING IT'LL GO --
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE.
DROWNED THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE
SYSTEM AND SO THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
HOPING WE DID NOT WANT TO
MANDATE IT BUT WE WANTED ALLOW.
THE FLEXIBILITY FOR THOSE
SMALLER COMMUNITY COLLEGE JUST
OF THAT TO DEVELOP THEIR AM CST
PROGRAMS.
OKAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ADJUSTER LEVER CATION
MISTER CHAIR --
UNDERSTAND THIS IS HAVE AN AYE
AYE RECOMMENDATION IT DOES --
DOES OKAY ON BOTH SIDES ON BOTH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SUPPORT
SUPPORT. TO ADD SAY NO OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS --
MADAM CHAIR IF YOU WOULD CALL
THE THE ROLE.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEDINA
AYE MEDINA AYE CHOI AYE CHOI AYE
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I IRWIN --
WHEN I KILEY LEVINE?
LEVINE I LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON SANTIAGO WEBER.
WEBER HI.
ADDRESS CHAIR READING. NINE ZERO
YOUR BILL IS OUT WOULD LEAVE IT
OPEN -- FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS.
SECOND ITEM ACR FOURTEEN MISLI
MORE.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS AT
FIRST I WANT TO ACCEPT THE
PROPOSED COMMITTEES CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS.
AND ACR FOURTEEN RECOGNIZES THE
WEEK OF MARCH.
THANK YOU I SAID THAT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
ANY.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
OF SPEAKERS IN AND SUPPORT OF
THE BILL
.
MANY RODRIGUEZ ON BEHALF THE
EDUCATION TRUST WEST HERE IN
SUPPORT OF ACR FOURTEENTH INTEND
TO A HEIGHTENED AWARENESS.
ON THE ON THE ONE MOMENT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE RON RAP
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ROSS I DEANDRE HERE WITH THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE OF THE CHANCELLOR OF THE
BOARD OF GOVERNORS ARE BIG
SUPPORTERS OF THE JEWEL IN THE
ROMAN PROGRAM.
IT'S SUPPORT STUDENT SUCCESS --
WE ARE WORKING WITH THE AUTHORS
OFFICE AND ARE AT OUR NEXT BOARD
MEETING WILL BE BRINGING THIS --
TO TO FOR THEIR CONSIDERATION
FOR SOME.
LESS THAN EVER IT ON BEHALF OF
ME COLLEGE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
HERE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MARK MCDONALD ON
BEHALF OF THE FOOTHILL DANCER
KERN PERALTA SAN BERNADINO SAN
DIEGO AND YUBA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE.
SAY NONE.
OF IT WAS OF MOTION BY.
MR LOW SECOND BY MR GABRIEL --
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
RESPECT THAT STERN AYE VOTE.
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND AS A FORMER HIGH
SCHOOL TEACHER COLLEGE
INSTRUCTOR.
I KNOW THE VALUE OF DUAL
ENROLLMENT IN OF SEEING MY OWN
HIGH SCHOOL PUPILS TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF IT AND SEEN THE
WITH DAVE.
GAIN FROM THAT FROM BILL ROLLED
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE MON FOR
BRINGING THIS RESOLUTION FORWARD.
AND THANK YOU ENCOURAGE ALL TO
CONSIDER MAKING EVERY THIRD WEEK
OF MARCH DUAL ENROLLMENT WEAK
AREA.
AND BETTER SECRETARY WOULD CALL
THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS BE ADOPTED AS
AMENDED TO THE CONCERNED CONSENT
CALENDAR.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE CHOI AYE
CHOI AYE ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I IRWIN --
WHEN -- WHEN
I KILEY LEVINE?
LEVINE I LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON.
SANTIAGO WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER HI. NINE ZERO YOUR BILL IS
OUT THINK WE GET LEAVE IT OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
NEXT UP WE HAVE --
AB.
THIRTY MR HOLDEN [inaudible]
WELCOME [inaudible]
AGREES
.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
I'D LIKE --
TO A PRESENT TO YOU A. B..
THIRTY AND I'D LIKE TO FIRST
START BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE
FOR WORKING WITH US ON THIS A
BILL THAT WE OBVIOUSLY HAVE A
GREAT DEAL OF PASSION AND
CONSISTENT SUPPORT FOR AND I
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEES --
COMMENDED BEHIND A DUAL
ENROLLMENT.
THE DECEMBER LIKE TO THINK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF PATTERSON.
FOR JOINING ME BUT HE'S NOT
GOING [inaudible]
TO OKAY.
BUT FOR FOLLOWING THE SCRIPT --
JUST SAY THAT.
THE RESEARCH HAS DEMONSTRATED
THE DUAL ENROLLMENT STUDENTS.
ARE MORE LIKELY TO ENTER COLLEGE
PERSISTING COLLEGE --
TO COMPLETION AND GRADUATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL.
THIRTY INCREASES ACCESS TO
COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY STREAMLINES
THE PROCESS TO DEVELOP STRONG
PARTNERSHIPS WITH K. THROUGH
TWELVE AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND REMOVES BARRIERS FOR
STUDENTS.
VAGUELY A. B..
THIRTY PREVENTS THE COLLEGE AND
CAREER ACCESS PATHWAYS SEE SEE
SEE CAP PARTNERSHIP ACROSS
CALIFORNIA FROM EXPIRING AT THE
END OF TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE
AND INSURERS DUAL ENROLLMENT
OPPORTUNITIES REMAIN AVAILABLE
TO STUDENTS.
WHO MAY NOT ALREADY BE COLLEGE
BOUND OR WHO ARE UNDER
REPRESENTED IN COLLEGE EDUCATION?
STREAMLINED THE PROCESS FOR
DEVELOPING DEVELOPING C. CAPPER
GRIMACED BETWEEN K. TWELVE AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS.
IT ADDS CONTINUATION HIGH SCHOOL.
HIGH SCHOOLS TO THE DEFINITION
OF STUDENTS THAT CAN BENEFIT
FROM DUAL ENROLLMENT PROGRAMS
ALLOWS UNITS COMPLETED AS PART
OF A C. CAB DUAL ENROLLMENT
PROGRAM TO CAL TOWARDS.
DETERMINING THEIR REGISTRATION
PRIOR COLLEGE.
ALLOWS HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS TO
COMPLETE ONE APPLICATION FOR THE
DURATION OF THEIR ATTENDANCE AT
A COMMUNITY COLLEGE AS A DUAL
ENROLLMENT.
STUDENT AND SIMPLIFIES THE
STUDENT APPLICATION.
PROHIBITS ACCESS IN ANY FEES THE
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS AND SEE CAP
COURSES INCLUDING STUDENTS IN A
DAHLE CONTINUATION HIGH SCHOOLS.
IN CLOSING WE HAVE SEEN MANY
STUDENTS SIX SUCCESSES SINCE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF SEE CAP IN TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN AND I WANT TO
CONTINUE TO ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA COMMITS.
DUAL ENROLLMENT AS A PERMANENT
AND SUCCESSFUL STRATEGY TO
CLOSING THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP IN
CREATING SEAMLESS PATHWAYS FROM
HIGH SCHOOL TO COLLEGE.
I'VE MET I HAVE WITH ME AND THEY
ARE HERE.
UGH GERSON SANCHEZ --
TO OFFER A STUDENTS PERSPECTIVE
AND WAS THAT NEVER AT VICE
PRESIDENT OF THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA TO
DISCUSS.
THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS
LEGISLATION AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR ABOUT [inaudible]
COULD HAVE.
A GOOD AFTERNOON --
CHAIR AS MOST DISTINGUISHED
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS CHRIS IN THE HEAD SANCHES.
AND I AM A STUDENT AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA DAVIS
AS WELL AS AN ALUMNI FROM EAST
LOS ANGELES COLLEGE AND JAMES A.
GARFIELD HIGH SCHOOL --
I WANT TO BEGIN BY THINKING
SOMEONE OR HOLDEN BY BRING FORTH
THIS VERY IMPORTANT BILL BECAUSE
WITHOUT THIS TYPE OF PROGRAM
BEING INSTITUTED I WOULD NOT BE
SITTING HERE.
IN FRONT OF ALL OF YOU
ADVOCATING FOR THIS PER THIS
PROGRAM AND DOING MOMENT I WOULD.
HAVE NOT HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
GRADUATE FROM HIGH SCHOOL --
I COME FROM OF LOW INCOME
COMMUNITY WHERE I HIGHER
EDUCATION IS OFTEN SEEMED AS A
DREAM IN THE DISTANCE.
AND AS AN UNDOCUMENTED STUDENT
THAT SEEM TO EVEN FURTHER OUT
DUE TO THE COSTS THAT COME TO
BEING A COLLEGE STUDENT --
AND BEING HAVING A FOR YOUR
FORTY INSTITUTION --
NOT SEEM LIKE A LIKELY CHOICE
THANKS TO DOING ROMAN NOT ONLY
ALLOWING ME TO GRADUATE FROM
HIGH SCHOOL BY COMPLETING THE
TECHNOLOGY AS WELL AS THE ARTS
PORTION TO GRADUATE FROM HIGH
SCHOOL IN --
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE IT OPEN THE
DOOR TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE ACUTE
THE COMMUNICORP EDUCATION FOR ME --
I NEVER THOUGHT THAT THE HIGHER
EDUCATION WAS GOING TO BE.
A GOOD CHOICE FOR ME --
I WAS DESTINED TO BE A WILDER
JUST LIKE MY FATHER I JUST LIKE
MY FATHER IS AND JUST FOLLOW IN
WITH THE LOS ANGELES WELDING
IRON WORKERS A COMMUNITY --
BUT THANKS TO THE DOOR WHEN
PROGRAM ALLOWING ME TO GRADUATE
OPENING THE DOORS TO WHAT A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE COULD OFFER ME
I WAS ABLE TO GO TO COMMUNITY
COLLEGE GRADUATE FROM HIGH
SCHOOL AND NOW BE A STUDENT AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
DAVIS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON AT CHAIR MEDINA
AND MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY
HIRED COMMITTEE --
I FIRST WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HOLDEN FOR HIS CONSISTENT
SUPPORT OF SEE CAN'T
PARTNERSHIPS AND DUAL ENROLLMENT.
AND I WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU
FOR YOUR PART IN MAKING POSSIBLE
THE C. CAP PARTNERSHIPS THAT
HAVE REALLY CHANGE THE
TRAJECTORY OF STUDENTS LIKE
GERSON.
THEY'VE MADE IT POSSIBLE FOR US
TO EXPAND DOING MOMENT AS A
STRATEGY THAT WORKS FOR ALL
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS.
NOT JUST A SUBSET --
I IT'S CAP 25% OF STUDENTS THAT
ARE SELECTED BY THE PRINCIPAL.
THEY SAID THIS IS A STRATEGY
THAT CAN WORK FOR ALL --
AB THIRTY IS A STEP THAT FURTHER --
MOVES US IN THE DIRECTION TO
FULLY EMBRACING DILLON ROMAN AS
A STRATEGY THAT WORKS --
AND OUR COLLEGES WE HAVE OVER
50% OF ALL COMMITTEE COLLEGE
DISTRICTS HAVE SEE CAP
PARTNERSHIPS AND I AB THIRTY
WILL MAKE IT POSSIBLE FOR MORE
PARTNERSHIPS TO BE DEVELOPED.
AND THOSE THAT HAVE IMPLEMENTED
HAVE SEEN SUCCESSES THEY'VE SEEN
A REDUCTION IN TIME TO DEGREE
I'M MORE DIVERSE SET OF STUDENTS
AND NOW HAVE EARLY COLLEGE
OPTIONS.
AND THEY'VE SEEN STUDENTS --
COMPLETE THEIR UC AND CSU
TRANSFER REQUIREMENTS AT A
FASTER PACE AND SAVING MONEY
ALONG THE WAY SO.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND
WE ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT.
I THINK OUT HERE WHO --
GO HEAD OF WHAT SORRY THANK YOU
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE --
MARK MCDONALD MCCALLUM GROUP ON
BEHALF OF THE FOOT HILL THE ENDS
OF AND YUBA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS ALL OF VERY MUCH IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU KYLE HIGHLAND ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA COULD BE COLLEGE
ADMINISTRATORS AND SUPPORT.
STEPHANIE GOLDMAN ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
ASSOCIATION FOR OCCUPATIONAL
EDUCATION INSTRUCTOR.
AND A GARAGE ON BEHALF OF THE
LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
DAVID NEVIN ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
AND THE SOUTH ORANGE COUNTY
COMMUNICORP DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
STILL SHE WAS TALKING ON BEHALF
OF THE SANTA MONICA COLLEGE IN
LOS ANGELES COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT SUPPORT.
NICOLAS CHAVEZ ON BEHALF OF LONG
BEACH CITY COLLEGE DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
I'M OF THE BILL.
ED -- BUT
JUST TO CLARIFY TO THE AUTHOR
STROLLED IT DID DID YOU STATE
THAT YOU WOULD ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS.
YES THANK YOU.
ANY.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM --
THE COMMITTEE.
I I I WANT TO THANK.
MR HOLDEN FOR BRING INTHE BILL
FORWARD --
AS HE DID A FEW YEARS BACK.
AND I AM VERY WHOLEHEARTEDLY
AGREE AS A FORMER A HIGH SCHOOL
TEACHER AND I ESPECIALLY LIKE
YOUR COMMENTS MISTER HOLDEN.
OF THE BENEFITS OF THIS COULD
HAVE FOR CONTINUATION HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS.
OF WHICH I WAS ONE ALSO AND I I
WOULD SAY.
THAT WE GIVE STUDENTS
OPPORTUNITY TO BE IN A DIFFERENT
ENVIRONMENT THEY WILL ACT AND
PERFORM DIFFERENTLY.
AND DUAL ENROLLMENT DOES THAT
FOR STUDENTS VERY MUCH.
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND
I'M GLAD YOU HAVE.
AND WITH THAT --
WILL CALL THE ROLL I HAVE A
QUESTION BEFORE.
BOARDING ALL RIGHT.
IS TO HOLD ON I HAVE A QUESTION
I OBVIOUS TO SUPPORT THAT
BECAUSE I A US --
NUMBER OF THE PLO.
I KNOW OUR IRVINE VALLEY COLLEGE
COMMITTEE COLLEGES IN US IN
IRVINE.
THEY HAVE A SPECIAL RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE A PARTICULAR ATTACKMAN
HIGH SCHOOL.
OF FOR THE DOOR ENROLLMENT.
AND THEN I A WASN'T QUITE SURE
WHY -- A A
AT THAT COMMUNITY COLLEGE OPENED
UP BUT AND THE WHAT DEVELOPED A
RELATIONSHIP BUT TO RECEIVE THE
STUDENTS OF FROM ONE PARTICULAR
HIGH SCHOOL.
WHERE YOU WILL BE --
ALLOW ANY YOU CAN APPLY FOR TO
WORK IN ONE MONTH OUT OF THE
CHOICE COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO
WITHOUT.
HAVING.
TO RELY UPON THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN COLLEGES DISTRICT COURT
AND HIGH SCHOOL DEVELOPER THAT
KIND OF AGREEMENT.
IT.
OF AND THAT THERE'S A PROBABLY
MORE SPECIFIC TARGETED ANSWER
THAT I'M GOING TO TURN TO OUR
WHATEVER'S RESPONSES.
TO ELABORATE ON BUT CANCERS YES
IN TERMS OF IT BEING A VERY.
ALL OF THE THE THE COLLEGES WITH
THE COLLEGE IN THE DISTRICT.
THAT THOSE STUDENTS HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY.
TO ATTEND.
IN THEIR DISTRICT OF THAT WOULD
GIVE THEM THE OPPORTUNITY
EXPOSURE TO A DUAL ROLE IN AND
THEN THE AGREEMENTS WOULD BE
BETWEEN.
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND IN
THAT AREA AND WITH THE THE A K.
THROUGH.
TWELVE THE SCHOOL TO SO THEY
HAVE THEIR AGREEMENTS AND THEY
WOULD.
DETERMINE --
LOCATION SUBJECT MATTER
INSTRUCTORS.
THAT OF SUBJECTS WOULD BE TAUGHT
AND THOSE KIDS WOULD HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY NOW IF THAT
COMMITTEE COLLEGE HAS A SPECIAL
RELATIONSHIP THAT'S SEPARATE
FROM.
FROM THIS BILL OKAY BASICALLY MY
QUESTION IS --
ASSIST SHARON --
100% FREE. TO CHOOSE THE COLLEGE
OF THEIR CHOICE HELP WALK FORCES.
ALL RATHER THAN BEING BOUND.
FIVE WHICH COLLEGES.
WE'RE OCT SEPT.
A CERTAIN HIGH SCORES AND THEN
ALSO ONLY CERTAIN COURSES.
BUT ARE I WOULD RATHER --
WOULD LIKE TO SEE.
JUST A 100% FREEDOM. FOR
STUDENTS SO THEY CAN NOT.
OF CHOOSE THEIR COLLEGE FORCE
AND THEY WANNA TAKE.
SO THE THIS BILL IS ADDRESSING
ONE TYPE OF DOING MOMENT OPTIONS
AT THE WHICH IS DAY COLLEGE AND
CAREER ACCESS PATHWAYS.
WHICH PROVIDE THE FRAMEWORK
UNDER WHICH COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND THE SCHOOL DISTRICT CAN
PARTNER --
ON A SET OF COURSES THAT ARE
DESIGNED TO STREAMLINE AND MAKE
IT FASTER FOR STUDENTS TO GET
THROUGH --
IT VERY SPECIFIC CLASSES THAT
THEY NEED IN ORDER TO BE READY
FOR COLLEGE AND EVENTUALLY STORY
AND THE LACK OF THAT KIND OF A
CONTRACT WHAT WE LOCATION SHIP
BUT THEN THOSE CHILDREN SO EVEN
IF THEY DESIRE. TO ENROLL MORE
BENEFITING FROM THIS BILL NOT
WILL NOT HAVE AN OPTION TO
LITERATURE YEAH ANOTHER TYPE OF
DOING MOMENT THAT DOES EXIST IS
ONE THAT --
IS -- JUST
AVAILABLE TO STUDENTS TO SELECT
A COLLEGE TO ATTEND THAT DOES
HAVE A CAP ON HOW MANY STUDENTS
CAN PARTICIPATE IN THAT.
BUT IT DOES PROVIDE THE FREEDOM
THAT YOU'RE REFERRING --
TO IF THAT SOMETHING THAT IS OF
INTEREST --
THIS IS STREAMLINED AND IT'S
NEED MOST IN ORDER TO BE READY
AND PREPARED --
AND AND A COST EFFECTIVE WAY FOR
THEM TO START WORKING TOWARDS
TRANSFERRED DEGREES.
SOUTH.
AND I'M HAPPY TO FOLLOW UP WITH
MORE DETAILS ARE VERY SPECIFIC
TO THE CASE THAT YOU'RE LOOKING
AT THE MY SECOND QUESTION IS SO
WHAT --
ORALLY --
THE AGREEMENT THE DETERMINE HOW
MANY --
CREDIT HOUR LIMITATION WAGES
JORDAN.
YEAR WALK BY SOME BUS MASTER
THEY CAN TAKE GOAL OR IS SET UP
TO THE STUDENT.
AT SO I UNDER CALLED IN CRACKS
PATHWAYS STUDENT CAN TAKE UP TO
FIFTEEN UNITS.
I PER SEMESTER.
WHICH IS JUST ABOVE THE FULL
TIME LOAD YEAH.
UNDER THIS UNDER THIS PROGRAM
YOU HAVE I MEAN IT'S VERY UNIQUE
YOU'VE CREATED A COLLEGE GOING
CULTURE WITHIN THESE COMMUNITIES
AND YOU ALSO HAVE STUDENTS THAT
ARE ACTUALLY.
GRADUATING FROM HIGH SCHOOL WITH
A A DEGREES.
AS WELL I UNDERSTAND NOW OKAY MY
QUESTION WAS THE WET WET --
THAT THE CREDIT LIMITATION.
IS -- SET BY
THE MONTEL WHY IS SET UP TO
INDIVIDUAL STUDENT.
YES -- UNDER
C. CAPITA AT FIFTEEN UNITS --
SO THAT BECAUSE THE STUDENTS ARE
ARE ARE ALSO HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS --
AND THAT IS SOMETHING THAT
RESEARCH HAS SHOWN REALLY WORKS
IS THE IN TERMS OF THE BALANCE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WE HAD A MOTION BY.
DOCTOR CHOI SECOND BY DOCTOR
RUMBULA --
MADAM SECRETARY IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE EDUCATION COMMITTEE.
MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE CHOI HI CHOI I
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I BLOOM.
BLOOM I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I IRWIN.
IRWIN I HIGHLY.
KILEY I LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW.
LOW I PATTERSON.
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I ELEVEN ZERO THE BILL IS
OUT.
THEIR ADDRESS ROBERT THANK YOU
COMMITTEE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
ANY AB MEMBERS.
THE NEXT BILL AB ONE FORTY MISS
CERVANTES.
WELCOME IS WOULD WANT THIS.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT AB
ONE FORTY TODAY THIS BILL IS A
RE INTRODUCTION OF AB SEVENTEEN
SIXTY SEVEN WHICH THIS COMMITTEE
APPROVED LAST YEAR.
ALTHOUGH WE HAVE MADE VALUABLE
INVESTMENTS IN HIGHER EDUCATION
SEVERAL UNDERGRADUATES EACH YEAR
RELY ON FEDERAL STUDENT LOANS TO
ENROLL AND COMPLETE.
COLLEGE YET IT IS BORN
DISPROPORTIONATELY BY VULNERABLE
GROUPS OF STUDENTS SUCH AS FIRST
GENERATION HOW GRANT STUDENTS
AFRICAN AMERICANS HISPANICS AND
LATINOS GRADUATES.
THE INSTITUTE FOR COLLEGE ACCESS
AND SUCCESS FOUND THAT THE
AVERAGE PERCENTAGE OF STUDENTS
IN DEBT FOR CALIFORNIA. FOR
CALIFORNIA GRADUATE OUT OF
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE NONPROFIT
COLLEGES 50% WHAT THE TOTAL DEBT
AVERAGE A 220-007-0080 FIVE
DOLLARS PER GRADUATE.
STUDENT LOAN COMPANIES OFTEN
PROVIDE SIX MONTHS GREAT GRACE
PERIOD BEFORE THEY ARE REQUIRED
TO REPAY BACK THEIR LOANS.
HOWEVER DATA SHOWS THAT SIX
MONTHS IS GENERALLY NOT ENOUGH
TIME FOR MANY STUDENTS WHO ARE
LOOKING AT TRANSITION INTO THE
WORK FORCE AND HAVE CHALLENGES.
IN THE NEEDED JUST TO POST
GRADUATE LIFE IT IS IMPERATIVE
THAT WE RECOGNIZE THAT TUITION
FREE AND DEBT FREE ARE NOT
SYNONYMOUS AND STUDENT DEBT.
SHOULD REMAIN A CONCERN THAT WE
AS A LEGISLATURE MUST ADDRESS.
THIS HIGHLIGHTS THE INSUFFICIENT
TIME STUDENTS HAVE TO CONSIDER
CAREER OPTIONS AND HINDERS
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES WHAT
STAGGERING STUDENTS.
ABILITY TO EXPERIENCED ABILITY
AND MAJOR LIFE EVENTS AB ONE
FORTY WILL PROVIDE TWO YEARS A
DEBT RELIEF FOR A FEDERAL
STUDENT LOAN. TO RECENT COLLEGE
GRADUATE WHO MEET CERTAIN
CRITERIA.
THIS PROGRAM IS ALREADY BE
ADMINISTERED IN THE STATE OF NEW
YORK.
COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB ONE
FORTY WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS CHAIRED JURIES JERRY
SO FROM THE CALIFORNIA STATE
STUDENT ASSOCIATION.
AND MELISSA BESET BY A STUDENT
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
MERCED --
AGO BIRTH.
GOOD AFTERNOON --
CAN EVEN MEMBERS AND GERMANY NOW
MY NAME IS SURGERY SO THAT THE
I'M THE ASSISTANT DIRECTOR FOR
GOVERNMENT.
SORRY X. SIX AS SYSTEM EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIPHATE'S IN
ASSOCIATION.
FIRST ONE OF THESE FOR THE YEAR --
WHICH REPRESENTS NEARLY HALF A
MILLION CSU STUDENTS ACROSS THE
STATE.
I WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CERVANTES FOR A IN THE
AFFORDABILITY CHALLENGES FACING
CSU STUDENTS WITH AB.
ONE FORTY WELL THE AFFORDABILITY
CHALLENGES FACING TODAY'S
COLLEGE STUDENTS ARE DIVERSE AND
DEEP --
TUITION IS RELATIVELY LOW IN THE
CSU -- BUT
ONLY 22% OF THE TOTAL COST OF
COLLEGE IS TUITION IN THE CSU.
THIS IS WHITE STUDENTS TODAY
AREN'T JUST STRUGGLING TO GET A
GOOD GRADE ON A MID TERM BUT
ALSO STRUGGLING TO FIGURE OUT
HOW THE BILL PAY THE RENT WITH
10% OF OUR STUDENTS --
BEING HOMELESS.
FIGURING OUT HOW THE FEED
THEMSELVES ON A REGULAR BASIS
WITH FORTY OVER 40% OF OUR
STUDENTS STRUGGLING TO FEED
THEMSELVES.
THIS IS THE THESE ARE THE
REASONS THAT COLLEGE STUDENTS
ACROSS SEGMENTS THE CALIFORNIA
CALLING ON THE LEGISLATURE AND
HIGHER EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS TO
FIX OUR FOR ARE BROKEN FINANCIAL
AID SYSTEM.
HOWEVER AT THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MENTIONED WHILE WE ARE WORKING
TO ADDRESS THESE GAPS IN THE
CURRENT FINANCIAL AID SYSTEM WE
MUST ALSO ADDRESS THE CURRENT
CRISIS THE STUDENT LOAN DEBT --
WHICH THE CALIFORNIA KICKSTART
MY FUTURE LOAN FORGIVENESS
PROGRAM SEEKS TO DO.
THE GROWTH IN STUDENT LOAN DEBT
TODAY UNDERSCORES THE DIRE
AFFORDABILITY CHALLENGES FACING
TODAY'S COLLEGE STUDENTS --
WHICH ARE UNIQUE --
WHICH ARE UNIQUE CHALLENGES THAT
ARE FACING TODAY STUDENTS --
UNIQUELY.
A FEW THERE IS A APPROXIMATELY
ONE POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
IN STUDENT LOAN DEBT --
NATIONALLY WHICH IS LARGER THAN
ALL AUTO LOAN DEBT AS WELL AS ON
LARGER THAN ALL CREDIT CARD DEBT.
IN THE LAST TEN YEARS STUDENT
LOAN DEBT HAS TRIPLED ON TO ITS
CURRENT AMOUNT.
AND FINALLY --
IT SHOULD BE NO SURPRISE THAT IN
CALIFORNIA WE LEAD THE NATION
AND SOON LEARNED THAT WITH A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY BILLION
DOLLARS AMONGST APPROXIMATELY
THREE POINT SEVEN MILLION
BORROWERS.
NOT ONLY IS THE TOTAL LOAN --
DEBT AN IMPORTANT FIGURE THAT
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED BUT WHO
WHO HOLDS THE DEBT IN CALIFORNIA
IS ALSO IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND --
AND AGAIN AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MENTIONED THIS IS REFLECTED AND
THAT BURDENS THAT FALL MORE
HEAVILY ON UNDER REPRESENTED
STUDENTS IN THE SET --
IN THE SEE IT CSU AS WELL AS LOW
INCOME STUDENTS.
ARE ORG ALONG WITH --
THE INSTITUTE FOR COLLEGE ACCESS
AND SUCCESS PUBLISHED REPORT IN
THE WINTER OF TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN WHICH INVESTIGATED
THIS ISSUE --
OF WHO HOLDS DEBT IN THE CSU.
IT FOUND THAT SIX IN TEN
STUDENTS WITH A BACHELOR'S
DEGREE WHO BORROWED HAD COME
FROM FAMILIES OF INCOMES NO
GREATER THAN TWENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR ANNUALLY.
ADDITIONALLY --
WHILE FIFTY BIRDS ARE HOW
SPENDING A LOT ROGER IT'S AT 57%
AND BLOCKING OUT AFRICAN
AMERICAN STUDENTS AT 76% HOLDING
DOT.
EVEN THOUGH THE AVERAGE --
DEBT FOR CSU STUDENTS IS BELOW
THE NATIONAL AVERAGE THIS REPORT
SHOWS THAT WHO HOLDS THAT THAT
IS THE THE GREATER CHALLENGE
THAT WE MUST.
ADDRESS AGAIN LASTLY THE
RESEARCH ALSO DONE BY TAKE A
SHOW THAT FIRST GENERATION
STUDENTS PAL RECIPIENTS AN
UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENTS ALL
SHOWED HIGHER RATES OF STUDENT
LOAN DEFAULT. FOR THESE REASONS
A PROGRAM LIKE THE ONE CREATED
BY A BEFORE --
ONE FORTY IS ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL
TO GIVE STUDENTS A BIT OF
FINANCIAL RELIEF WHILE THEY
ESTABLISH THEIR CAREERS AND HELP
THEM BETTER MANAGE THEIR LOAN
DEBT AS THEY ULTIMATELY ARE ON
THE ROAD TO FULLY PAY OFF THEIR
LOANS -- WE
ARE YOUR YESVOTE ON AB ONE
FORTY TODAY THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEDINA AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS MELISSA THE
SERRA AND I'M A FOURTH YEAR
PSYCHOLOGY MAJOR AT UC MERCED
AND THE GOVERNMENT RELATIONS AID
WITH THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA STUDENT ASSOCIATION.
WHICH REPRESENTS TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY THOUSAND STUDENTS OF THE
UC SYSTEM AND THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CERVANTES FOR ALLOWING US
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB.
ONE FORTY AB ONE FORTY IS
IMPORTANT TO ME AND TO USE THE
ESSAY BECAUSE IT ENSURES THAT
FINANCIALLY VULNERABLE STUDENT
BORROWERS ARE NOT HINDERED BY
STUDENT LOANS.
AND HAVE THE RESOURCES TO
SUCCEED AND THE POST GRADUATE
LIFE THE COST OF ATTENDING
COLLEGE IS MORE THAN TUITION
ALONE AS IT INCLUDES COSTS FOR
FOOD AND HOUSING. 44% OF YOU SEE
UNDERGRADUATES ARE FACING FOOD
AND SECURITY AND THESE COSTS CAN
LEAD STUDENTS TO TAKE OUT
STUDENT LOANS.
ALL WE HAVE TO DO IS LOOK AT THE
FACTS FROM STUDENT DEBT AT THE
UC.
NEARLY THREE OUT OF EVERY FIVE
YOU SEE STUDENTS GRADUATE WITH
SOME LEVELS OF STUDENT LOAN DEBT.
THE AVERAGE STUDENT LOAN DEBT AT
THE UC DOLLARS.
MOST CONCERNING BELOW IS CAN THE
LOWEST INCOME STUDENTS AT THE UC
GRADUATE WITH THE MOST AMOUNT AT
THAT AT TIMES WOULD NEARLY
DOUBLE OR TRIPLE.
THE AMOUNT OF DEBT THAN THAT OF
THE HIGHER INCOME COUNTERPARTS.
CITY LET STUDENT LOAN DEBT ALSO
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTS BAR
WAS OF COLOR.
AT MY CAMPUS UC MERCED WHICH IS
A HISPANIC SERVING INSTITUTION
WERE NEARLY THREE FOURTHS OF THE
STUDENTS ARE FIRST GENERATION.
AND THREE FIFTHS OF WHOM ARE
POWER RECIPIENTS OVER 70% OF
STUDENTS GRADUATE WITH THAT
WHICH IS A STAGGERING NUMBER AND
I BELIEVE THAT AB ONE FORTY WILL
HELP THE BEST HELP SUPPORT.
THE STUDENTS WHO ARE FACING
LOANS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
RON WRAPPING UP IN CALIFORNIA WE
HAD ORIGINALLY TEACHERS AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU FATHER FOR
PROVIDING LEADERSHIP ON THIS
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE WITH THE BILL
[inaudible]
CHOI.
THANK YOU CHAIR OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SOMEONE TENNIS
[inaudible]
A OF UNDERSTAND.
THE INTENT OF YOUR P. L.
[inaudible]
HELPING --
SHOULDN'T IS.
ALLEVIATE THE THEIR BURDEN.
WHEN THEY GRADUATE THE?
I'M COLLEGES SO.
WITH THE SCORE DEBT [inaudible]
BUT THE INCOME DRIVEN REPAYMENT
PLAN -- IS A
DESIGNED TO MAKE US SUCH A DANCE
STUDENT LOAN --
MANAGEABLE BY REDUCING THE
BARREL IS SAW.
A PAYMENT AMOUNT --
AS MUCH AS A IN ALL.
TACK DURING ALL THEY ARE
CIRCUMSTANCES --
AND THAT ALLOWING PAYMENTS TO
COLE S. ROY IS A ZERO DOLLARS.
AND THE OVER THE PERIOD.
AND WE ALL KNOW THAT THEY ARE
ALL SOUL MANY KINDS OF LAW --
AS CHILDREN SCHOLARSHIPS AND
LOAN PROGRAM SO --
TO A FOR THEM TO GRADUATE.
NOW WHEN THEY GRADUATE.
THEY ARE EQUIPPED. TO GET A JOB
IN THE IT FIELD.
I'M VERY CURIOUS.
YOU MENTIONED FIRST GENERATION.
IMMIGRANTS WHICH I AM.
AND MINORITY PEOPLE WALK OUT OF
THE PEOPLE.
WILL HAVE MORE LIKELY --
TO HAVE --
OF MORE DEBT SO THAT ORDER.
AND THIS ONE YOU'LL BE IT IS A
LIMITING WHEN THE STUDENTS SO --
INCOME IS TO LESS THAN FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS --
THEN THEY WOULD BE YOU ARE
ELIGIBLE.
I'M I'M CURIOUS.
WITH THE STATE --
SEGMENTS OF THE POPULATION TO
WALK RIGHT TO IT.
WE'RE LIKELY END UP BUT WITH THE
SUCH ALERT LOW PAID JOBS
[inaudible]
NO WHY.
AT THAT WOULD BE MY FIRST
QUESTION AND THEN I HAVE SOME
SIMPLE QUESTIONS.
WELL AS WE KNOW I DIFFERENT
PARTS OF OUR STATES ARE DOING
BETTER THAN OTHERS AND IT'S A
REGIONAL ISSUE AS WELL SO
DEPENDING ON WHERE YOU'RE GOING
TO COLLEGE.
HOW WERE YOU GRADUATES AND A LOT
OF STUDENTS HAVE TO LOOK FOR FOR
WORK?
OUTSIDE OF THEIR AREA THAT THEY
GRADUATED AND AND THIS IS AN
ISSUE THAT WE'VE BEEN SEEING
YEAR AFTER YEAR WITH GRADUATES --
BUT THE OVERALL ISSUE IS
CONCERNING.
ARE GROWING CRISIS IN STUDENT
LOAN DEBT.
STUDENT LOANS ARE THE SECOND
LARGEST CONSUMER DEBT SEGMENT
AND HAVE SURPASSED HOME EQUITY.
A REVOLVING DEBT AUTO LOANS AND
CREDIT CARD DEBT BALANCES
SHORTLY AFTER THE RECESSION.
AND SO THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT I
BELIEVE WE AS A LEGISLATURE MUST
LEAN AND ON AND ADDRESS.
AND WE MUST TO DO THIS BY PASSED
SEED POLICIES I THAT ADDRESSES
VERY ISSUE.
I WILL THOUGH TURN IT OVER --
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT TODAY
SHOULD THEY WANT TO ADD ON I
MEAN I I WOULD REITERATE THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS COMMENTS I'D
SAY THAT SEEING THE THE THE
GROWTH IN STUDENT LOAN DEBT OVER
THE COURSE OF THE LAST TEN YEARS
AND SING AT TRIPLE I THINK
UNDERSCORES.
HOW BIG OF A CRISIS THIS IS
AGAIN IN THE CSU IT AS YOU WOULD
ASSUME WITH A LOW TUITION RATE
AND THE FACT THAT MANY OF OUR
STUDENTS DON'T PAY TUITION THAT
IT WOULDN'T BE AN ISSUE BUT?
AFFORDING THE TOTAL COST OF
ATTENDANCE AND BEING ABLE TO
LIVE IN CALIFORNIA WHILE
PURSUING A DEGREE HAS BEEN A
UNIQUE CHALLENGE TODAY IN A WAY
THAT IT MIGHT NOT HAVE BEEN
TWENTY OR THIRTY YEARS AGO JUST
SEEING THAT GROWTH AND STUDENT
LOAN DEBT.
YOU KNOW MY QUESTION WAS --
STILL RUNS OUT NOT.
ABOUT THE FACT THAT THIS IS TO
RINSE OUT GRADUATING WITH IT --
WITH THE TUITION DEBTS.
YUP COLLEGES ARE EXPENSIVE.
AND MY A MY TWO MAJOR QUESTIONS
WORLD WHY CERTAIN SECTORS OF THE
POPULATION [inaudible]
ON A ARE STRUGGLING IN A PAYING.
AND WITH THE SAME EQUAL OR
DEGREE SO WHEN THEY GRADUATE WE
ADOPT OUR LOAN FORGIVENESS A
PROGRAM.
NOT A SCHOLARSHIP NUMBER --
TWO WAS THAT THE ALREADY.
INCOME DRIVEN NOT A REPAYMENT
PLAN --
ALLOWS -- TO
BEFORE THE INDIVIDUALS HEY.
THIS SO YOU'RE AFTER YEAR.
HALL.
ALLOWING THEIR LIVING EXPENSES.
A AND THEN ONE OF THE
COMFORTABLE AMOUNT OF AND SO --
NOW STATE THAT COMES IN.
AS MUCH AS OF FORTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
WE WE WE TRY TO PROVIDE AS MUCH
SCHOLARSHIP ORDER THE LOAN.
AND THEN I'VE I THINK THIS
SHOULD BE.
OF MORE ENCOURAGING FOR THEM TO
GET A JOB AND ENCOURAGING --
BUT THE EMPLOYERS TO PAY --
RESPECTABLE.
A SALARY WITH A BACHELOR'S
DEGREE.
WHEN WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THE A
MAJORITY WOULD BE --
UNDERGRADUATE THE CHILDREN.
OF GRADUATES TO WE ARE SPEAKING
ABOUT THE AND THE MOST CASES OUT
OF THE B. K. R..
O. DIDN'T DISSIPATE THE THEIR
BASIC SALARY PROBABLY MINIMUM
THRESHOLD DOSE.
. FOR FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS BELOW.
HERE.
BUT THE WHY IS CERTAIN.
GROUP BOB POPULATION THAT YOU
MENTIONED.
THEY THEY THEY ARE.
UP.
MORE SUFFERING FROM THIS --
THEY NEED A LEG UP.
I'LL EXPLAIN MY SITUATION FOR
EXAMPLE --
YOU KNOW WHEN I WAS GROWING UP --
MY PARENTS HAVE COME HERE TO
THIS COUNTRY THEN HOW MUCH --
MONEY -- DO
KNOW THE EDUCATION --
BUT I'M IS GET THROUGH SCHOOL
SYSTEM -- I
WENT TO UCLA --
WE HAD I HAD TO TAKE A LOAN.
PLAIN AND SIMPLE BUT I ALSO HAD
TO HELP --
WITH FAMILY INCOME BECAUSE IT
WASN'T ENOUGH --
OFF MY PARENTS A MINIMUM WAGE --
TO BE ABLE TO PAY FOR RENT AS
DID MY BROTHER --
BUT I THINK THE THE THESE THE
SIMPLE ANSWER IS --
THEY JUST DON'T HAVE THE MONEY.
IT'S IT'S A MUCH MORE
COMPLICATED THAN THAT.
AND I DON'T SEE A PROBLEM WITH
PASSED A BILL THAT HELPS US
WITHIN TWENTY COMES THE DEBT
BECAUSE IT IS THE ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT ISSUES.
FACING THIS COUNTRY --
BUT I DO WANT TO STICK TO THE
QUESTION THAT YOU'RE ASKING I.
I'LL AND ANSWER FROM MY OWN
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE --
HOUSE POOR PEOPLE CHOOSE THE
POOR -- YOU
KNOW THIS IS A NO DIFFERENT THAN
THE YOU KNOW YOU YOU WOULD
CHOOSE TO BE A TO HAVE SCHOOL
LOANS AND YES I DID WORK I WORK
FULL TIME --
AND I WHEN I WAS GOING TO UCLA
MOST OF THE TIME --
BUT IT WASN'T ENOUGH TO MAKE
BILLS -- IT
WAS ENOUGH TO MAKE THE BILLS SO
I HAD TO TAKE LOANS AND YES I
DID TAKE FINANCIAL AID --
BUT I DON'T REMEMBER THE NUMBERS
OFF THE TOP OF MY HEAD THE CHAIR
CAN CORRECT ME.
BUT IT'S GOT TO BE ABOUT WHAT IS
IT THIRTY TWO THIRTY FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER YEAR --
FOR STUDENT GOING TO UC SYSTEM
AND IT'S A WAS A TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS --
THE GO TO THE CSU SYSTEM FOOT
THAT'S PRETTY EXPENSIVE --
AND IF YOU COME FROM A WORKING
FAMILY AGAIN OF THE STATE YOU
JUST DON'T HAVE THE MONEY YOUR
POOR.
IT ADDS UP AND SO --
THERE'S A REASON WHY PEOPLE GET
LOANS.
AND AND AND I'M ALSO FAMILIAR
WITH ALL THE ALL THE THINGS THAT
A LONG CAN PROVIDE --
AFTERWARDS RIGHT YOU CAN DIFFER
YOU CAN GET CERTAIN THINGS BUT
THE BASIC ANSWERS.
PEOPLE POOR OR THE CAN.
FOR MY GO BACK TO THE OTHER BIG.
WHAT A COMMON ANSWER ABSOLUTELY
THIS IS A STORY THAT WE HEAR
ACROSS THE STATE WHEN STUDENTS
COME TO OUR OFFICES IN THE
CAPITAL IN THE DISTRICT OFFICE
TO SHARE WITH US WHAT THEIR
GREATEST BURDENS ARE?
AND AS A LEGISLATOR IS MY
RESPONSIBILITY.
TO TRY TO ADDRESS THOSE THROUGH
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WHICH IS
WHY THIS BILL IS BEFORE YOU
TODAY.
THANK YOU.
YEAH JUST A FOR YOUR INFORMATION
TO FORMAL ONE PIECE OF
INFORMATION I'LL BE INTRODUCING
AB -- THREE
FIFTY TO ENCOURAGE.
ALL THE PARENTS SO OUR RELATIVE
SO IT Y. E. IL OR OUT.
ANY EVEN COMPANIES. TO ANY.
IN ALL YOUNGSTERS TO SAVE MONEY
CAUGHT THE IRS OF FIVE TWENTY
NINE PLAN.
AND A CALIFORNIA IS STILL ONE
THE ONE OF THE FEW --
STAY SO WHICH DOES NOT TEXTED
DEDUCTION --
EVEN THOUGH THE GROWTH OF THE
FUND -- IS
NOT GONNA BE TAXABLE WRESTLING
SAID THAT THE AMOUNT THIS USED.
TO FOR EDUCATION PURPOSES SO
WHEN THEY GO TO COLLEGE.
SO WHAT ARE BE INTRODUCING --
A MORE SAVINGS PLAN AND THE
ENCOURAGING PARENTS TO
PARTICIPATE THE SO THAT THE
BURDEN WOULD BE NOT TO THE
GOVERNMENT UP BUT THE
ENCOURAGING.
UP PARENTS SO OF THE TO STOP
EARLY AND THE GOVERNMENT IS --
INCENTIVIZING.
THAT THE IF I SAVE A ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS TODAY.
AT THE END THAT THE PORTION OF
WOULD BE TAX CREDIT A TAX --
DEDUCTIBLE SO AS AN
ENCOURAGEMENT.
SO.
I I AM MORE IN IN IN THAT --
OF PROVIDING A SCHOLARSHIP SO
EARLY ON AND I ONCE YOU GRADUATE.
YOU HAVE ALREADY VOTING POWER
RATHER THAN.
COUPLE MONTHS UNTIL YOU DIE WE
IF SO.
WHAT THE GRADUATE IF I WOULD
HAVE A AND I'M A LITTLE BIT
CONCERNED?
NOT SEEN ANYWHERE QUESTIONS
RESERVE WANT THIS --
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
WHAT IT THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING IN --
THE BILL FORD I ATE A AGREE WITH
YOU THE AMOUNT OF DEBT THAT
STUDENTS HAVE.
AFTER GRADUATION FROM COLLEGE --
IS PRESENTING MANY CHALLENGES TO
THEM --
AMONG THEM --
THE ABILITY TO BUY A NEW HOUSE
AND PURSUE THE AMERICAN DREAM.
I WOULD ALSO ENCOURAGE THE THE
AUTHOR TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
C. SACK IN ORDER TO BEST
DETERMINE HOW THE GOALS OF THE
BILL.
CAN BE ACHIEVED SO WE HAD A
MOTION MR LOW SECOND BY DOCTOR
WEBER THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
OF MADAM SECRETARY COULD CALL
THE ROLL.
MEDINA I MEDINA I CHOI.
CHOI NO ARAMBULA [inaudible]
BLOOM.
I GABRIEL.
GABRIEL I IRWIN --
WHEN I KILEY?
KILEY NO LEVINE.
LEVINE I LOW LOW I PATTERSON
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER I EIGHT TO YOUR BILL IS
OUT LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU [inaudible]
YEAH YEAH YEAH YEAH.
WE'RE GOING TO A TWO THE ADD
ON'S.
WITH ALL THE BILL OKAY AS FAR
ADOPTING THEY COMMITTEE RULES
ARAMBULA [inaudible]
KILEY.
KILEY NO.
PATTERSON SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I
RIGHT [inaudible]
ADOPTION. EIGHT ONE THE RULES
HAVE BEEN ADOPTED.
OKAY AB [inaudible]
THIRTY PATTERSON. ELEVEN ZERO A.
B.. THIRTY THIRTY IS OUT.
AB TWO THREE NINE KILEY.
KILEY I PATTERSON SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I ELEVEN ZERO A. B. TWO
THIRTY NINE IS OUT.
AB [inaudible]
ONE FORTY ARAMBULA [inaudible]
PATTERSON. EIGHT TWO AB ONE
FORTY IS OUT.
ACR FOURTEEN KILEY.
KILEY I PATTERSON SANTIAGO
[inaudible]
SANTIAGO I ELEVEN ZERO ACR
FOURTEEN IS OUT. FIVE MILLION
SECOND [inaudible] FIVE SO JUST
ABOUT THE VISION OF BUT A LOT OF
OKAY YOU KNOW.
WE'RE GONNA LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR FIVE MINUTES --
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
THE FACT THAT HE
THE FULL VIDEO
.
COMMITTEE HIGHER EDUCATION IS A
JERK